At least eight people killed in Russian air strikes
in Ukraine's second largest city Kharkiv.
In Odessa, official say a Russian missile hit a utility facility
killing a civilian worker.
Ukraine's southern regions
including the port city of Odessa
are often targeted by Russian missile and drone attacks.
In a show of continuing support,
Germany's chancellor announced the allocation of €28 billion
for Ukraine's military during a visit to the Romanian capital
book arrest. Olaf Schultz says
bolstering Ukrainian defences will prevent the war from escalating.
Meanwhile, Russia has released video of fighter jets
said to be targeting northern Donetsk.